the house going red my name is Pierre
and welcome to Aikido know your own
night of the sacrifice it's a Japanese
game and if you follow me on Twitter you
know I've been [ __ ] trying to get
this piece of [ __ ] working all day um I
I heard about this game maybe a year ago
and I heard it's going to be trance fan
translated but when I last check on it
it seems like no one is actually working
on it anymore and I got tired of waiting
what's interesting about it first of all
I'm standing on the Wii Balance Board it
uses the Wii Balance Board to run and so
I thought it could be funny I heard that
you really have to run for your life
sometimes on the Wii Balance Board I
thought I could be a funny thing in a
Wii game regardless if the game is
Japanese or not if you girls want to
help and translate some important things
about the story I'd be more than happy
to put annotations and give you credit
for it
what I do know is that this is a
protagonist and we can name all the
characters obviously I can really do it
because I don't [ __ ] speak Japanese
um but this is my love interest
I guess we'll call her Stephanie because
she looks like the following is it go
get it
ha ha ha ha I know all right so this is
pinky I guess I'll call her Jennifer and
this is the the bro I guess Jennifer and
the bro have a love interest as far as
I'm concerned and I guess this will be
mr. chair uh and yeah I think the story
is that we're going to mr. chair house
because his dad is disappeared or
something and it starts off with a
tutorial pretty much but I wanted to go
through it really quick and regardless
so yeah it probably took me like the
entire [ __ ] day to get this game to
work I hope it's gonna be worth it I
heard it's pretty scary and it looks
pretty [ __ ] scary honestly we all
know Japanese people do the of course is
holding a Nintendo yes Japanese people
do the best horror games this is how it
is and it's a shame this one wasn't
translated oh yeah of course it doesn't
work anymore [ __ ] my life my brother
is finally works I didn't figure out
that now we actually know how to make it
work but goddamn even when I think I'm
done I end up getting trouble again that
took me probably like another 30 minutes
kids is happy alright go [ __ ] yourself
pity
wait hey to we're told is to play this
game as a joke there bro Thank You Russ
alright is it working yeah it's working
all right how the box
oh yeah oh look it's blonde over there
oh [ __ ] this is actually kind of [ __ ]
creepy can I go back in I should not you
can't let you do that kids that's what
the game says alright I guess that means
we got to go in this creepy [ __ ]
corridor unless we go in here can't let
you do that so fast my name is Sal
why the [ __ ] did I come from there I
feel sup
where is it come what the [ __ ] what are
you coming brah whoa hello heads you're
a [ __ ] idiot
alright yeah I knew that hello are you
walk in this game it's [ __ ] awesome
all right telephone what do you want
let's go with a blunt bent that's a good
idea
[ __ ] man alright hey continues yes
hello window it's funny to shake got
everything was okay here alright keep
that door open that's nice
that's probably just the window ah a
bloody toilet look like someone was on
their period again why did I close the
door what oh oh oh it's dripping from
there oh that's [ __ ] creepy man you
can't have your period from another
floor
I say take a period to the next level ah
pop where the [ __ ] did she go what the
[ __ ] is she doing away
all right hello don't think we're
worried about here oh all right I'm
taking that don't kill my friend okay
that's nice it's a ghost there what the
[ __ ] how do I get over these all right I
can go here why would you do that go
come back down I'll [ __ ] kill you
whoa whoa oh okay I'm running I'm
running I'm running I'm running I'm
running I'm running I'm running oh oh oh
oh hey [ __ ] - I got ya oh [ __ ] that
hello the [ __ ] is going on here I feel
so awkward in the second we board all
right that's nice ahh oh [ __ ] don't make
it dark don't make it out woman no no no
nice I need advice what the [ __ ] hello
soprano
it's [ __ ] stairs everywhere in this
game alright what you want girl I got
nothing for you
I got nothing hello at least we found
out with a pair of camera why did that
crying son Oh what she's looking at
something I'm gay that it right the hell
they should go I don't trust this pin
bras she was looking at something I
don't know she's probably drunk like
everyone else in this game why do you
have to turn out the light system
I can't leave apparently no bueno
uh-oh what the hell what's up cap what
what's happening
they took a bath together and it was
nice okay
oh that's nice I enjoy that all right so
that's like 23 chapters and they're all
really quick so let's just go with next
one why as well
I saw that one like a mouse like a me at
you 4s all right going down did it did
it did it get it
best running Abbot I might as well
[ __ ] ignore that I'm like I gotta get
something whoa dad is creepy
or should I see you that I don't try to
jump scare me bro Oh Oh going back in
that go ah there we go
all right whoa whoa share the [ __ ] out
oh so many [ __ ] goals hello friend
don't kill me mother look
alright it looks like you can't see me
stupid [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] man oh let's ignore her for that
all right
don't want to walk into that hey want a
hug but I'm gonna not give it to them
it's [ __ ] creepy man oh it's a
nailing this [ __ ] [ __ ] creepy [ __ ]
alright whoa
second Mitch
oh I'm pulling them that's nice what's
in here oh Sid ah okay come now come
from here penduline you learn more
things every day Braz isn't that lovely
open that good what
what the [ __ ]
I'm the [ __ ] what the hell am I supposed
to do there you just [ __ ] came out
named J said alright
one small sack
don't mom numbering
ah [ __ ] doesn't work out that well
alright and try that again
oh you see him in the door is that you
do Oh piss is not attached don't ya oh I
[ __ ] suck at that but how am I
supposed to know what he does huh how am
I supposed to know what do you do my
balls hurt anyway Oh Oh is he gonna
punch me
it doesn't even notice me ah oh my god
that's America
ah about here lady nerves ha ha ha ha
Wow all right it's going here open
oh [ __ ] what is up in this room then
maybe I'm supposed to hide from area
buckle up buddy I'm not whadya no I have
not
night going sauce hey go away
there we go good event dad dad dad
all right so we have to wait Fred pass I
have this way well this way [ __ ] my
pulse is out of control sometimes when I
run oh sure is too coming puzzle oh [ __ ]
oh yes and she is waiting for you John
oh but name that [ __ ] no it doesn't
open Bruce okay don't panic don't cut
don't panic don't panic panic
open it doesn't open either going there
foot foot jump on
all right here here this here this hair
this they trick man what the [ __ ] what
do you want hey boy how you then ah what
ah
[ __ ] man this [ __ ] case crazy
we're just not looking back and we're
going in here oh no uh-uh
what is that saying nail that [ __ ]
hell yeah mother Moya how's the air for
the maca nail that [ __ ] uh-uh-uh-uh
nail that [ __ ] uh-uh we get to I want
to do I like a little jiggle it soothes
my mind and we don't like a new one for
that cool I love this game so far I'm
glad all that [ __ ] thing I said this
[ __ ] up to it's totally totally worth
it
totally worth it oh man all right let me
try one more a little bit just a little
bit just a little bit little boy
all right watch your weight
crepey Holloway nice nice what is that a
radio Oh God must blinks there it's
[ __ ] running time to curve it to do so
good oh no nice bedding you got quite
nice right there today
oh [ __ ] Stefan oh yes
ah he does not look friendly it's not
[ __ ] with him hi I'm Matt lovely Shore I
agree oh ah ah ah
Friday ah what is this thing what is
this a kid's go [ __ ] yourself
it's well wash that bottle oh [ __ ] I
want to talk about now
hello call me back later what what what
what the [ __ ] is going up ah ah [ __ ]
going going
ah [ __ ] oh thank god
I thought it was gonna die that for a
second ah [ __ ]
alright we're good again let's go back
up I can't oh I can what hi there's
someone up there
it's the phone here Stephanie what are
you oh oh that's not divani
they tricked me Oh what the [ __ ] do you
want now
fine I'll go down here that's what you
watching alright
move [ __ ] see if I give a [ __ ]
another time for you and you're blocking
don't cock-block me from step funny
that's right you don't do that
alright let's get a nice ball there whoa
alright I'm a lumberjack oh I'm okay
okay but I gotta warn old it so far they
hi hey come back here high five
so funny so funny what the [ __ ] are you
doing why don't you do it girl
don't jump don't do it so funny
at bench I press that's all I had the
time ahead for today hope you enjoyed
this game I had really enjoyed it I
think bras well as well anyway I created
and really have songs especially when I
got a new series going I really
appreciate it like in their fourth one
it looks care is fun anyway hi go
hiiiiii
there we go if it doesn't open hand but
that [ __ ]